père Palmade n'est pas malade c'est tout
point ça c'est peine vraiment pour toi
c'est pas une vraie maladie pour moi non
quand tu t'en fous plein de PIF tout le
week-end parce que tu as les moyens de
dépenser de l'argent d'acheter de la cam
de faire des fêtes pas de problème cet
effet
même les pauvres faites vos fêtes il y a
pas de problème mais quand il arrive un
drame ne venez pas me sortir l'excuse de
la maladie
il est malade et responsable
alors peut-être que tu es mal entouré
peut-être qu'autour de toi ça va pas tu
es mal entouré tu as pas d'amis parce
que tous les gens qui se qui se proclame
hamides Pierre Palmade aujourd'hui mais
qui l'ont laissé pendant 30 ans dans
cette merde jusqu'à temps qu'on en
arrive à ce jour-là là ne me dites pas
que vous êtes ses amis vous n'êtes pas
ses amis moi si demain j'ai un ami qui
qui est malade comme vous dites je
laisse pas là-dedans je vais le sortir
de là dedans